all right can I risk sounding weird in
addressing the fact that the animals in
this movie had [ __ ] usually in an
animation a little animal would have
just like a little fuzzy button that's
it this one the cats walking away her
tails up it's just like bow and you're
like oh okay that that cat is showing
the entire theater her gum that's if you
got it flaunt it
the secret life of pets so the secret
life of pets revolves around Max's the
main dog in this movies voiced by louis
c.k I love Louie CK and Max's owner
brings home a new big dog and Max isn't
having eyes like I know you need to go
then through a series of events they get
captured by the pound and then they
escape and then they just takes them on
an adventure through the city Toy Story
meets adventures in babysitting for
animals pretty much as movie did have
enjoyment in it I mean first of all
louis c.k was great because he has that
just mopey tone that we're all
accustomed to for louis c.k it's
endearing and it's loving yet it's kind
of depressed sounding admittedly I just
find this premise interesting I mean it
worked for Toy Story and I think it's a
genius premise for pets also it's just
like you think everything's normal and
then when you turn your back or you
leave or you go to work you go to school
everything you thought didn't actually
come to life comes to life and they have
their own little like societies and
their own adventures their own
conversations it's just I just like that
it is a little different than Toy Story
in the sense that it's kind of like look
who's talking really where it's like I
mean they can't talk English they just
like to the person they're just barking
but to the animals they're talking so I
guess it'd be like look who's talking
now you see I haven't seen that neither
have you so be quiet you're typing in
the comment section right now that
you've seen that movie aren't you okay
go for it I'll wait we're really the
magic just kind of grinds to a halt and
slows down about halfway through this
movie I was just really racking my brain
I was like let the magic leave the movie
for the first act of it I was in it and
it's from a couple of things I think
first of all pacing done no kid the
patient kind of ground to a halt
and you're over it because the gimmick
that first draws you into the movie the
fact that oh these pets are sentient and
they have lives that just that leaves
now you got to fill it in with in actual
good movies and when you fill it in with
an alright movie that is enjoyable
enough but not a great movie just you
feel it because there's better stuff out
there Kevin Hart did his best as the
villainous bunny who's just ultimately
insane seriously this is crackhead crazy
eyes bunny with Kevin Hart's voice so he
is the perfect voice actor for that role
and that would have been fine but it's
the fact that you're distracted with all
these characters there is such a large
cast of supporting characters in this
movie that none of them really have a
big opportunity to shine a couple of
them do the standouts are this little
fluffy white dog whose look
from max and this bird that she finds
big Falcon or eagle or hawk or whatever
bird he is I don't know because I'm not
an old man who feeds birds on a roof so
I just I don't know that [ __ ] he was
voiced by Albert Brooks Nevis the gans
down my favorite supporting character in
the movie but there are so many
supporting characters it's kind of like
cry prefer Chrono Trigger you know
Chrono Trigger has a few characters that
you really get to know but that's all
you get but that you get to know the
bigger life of pets goes the Chrono
Cross rod was just like all these
characters are in this movie and none of
them really shines up that's use what
you get of a couple of standouts and
then 48 other animals that are just kind
of in the background in the end I will
say adults will thank the movies alright
kids will think it's better it's a
serviceable movie it's a fine movie in
the end I thought the movie was cute but
the movies not as good is either you or
your kids probably want the movie to be
you probably look in your blu-ray or DVD
pile at home you'll find a better
animated movie for your kid to watch it
was like I'm ripping and dogging on this
movie a bit more than I wanted to in the
end I really did walk out with a smile
of it okay that's fine alright now let's
go home I feel like I'm in the middle
I'm writing this one this is like reason
151 I don't like writings but I will say
the secret life of pets is actually a
good time no alcohol required at matinee
price sometimes I throw that in there
because I like to confuse you and I'm
not even like holding the whole like
it's kind of like Toy Story for pets
thing against it because it is like Toy
Story for pets and then again if I hold
that against Secret Life of pets I have
to hold against Toy Story the fact that
they ripped off the Brave Little Toaster
because Brave Little Toaster really came
up with that premise first alright guys
are the secret life of pets have you
seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite animated film of
the summer so far there you go whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you